he uh is uh one of our favorites
certainly when everything uh patriots
crops up this is who we reach out to the
man's been covering the patriots forever
in a day for nbc sports boston back here
on the rich eisen show is none other
than tom carr how are you tom
hi handsome how are you i'm fine are you
the sexiest man alive in new england
right now is that what it is that's the
sexiest man in my house right now
although i got some strong competition
from 22 year old tim curran very good
working at home remotely
tim e karin is it an e also no he's in r
okay tim r current okay very good
so uh are the patriots in on odell or
they're not right now they're they're
banging on the window they're banging on
the glass saying hey hey look at us
uh and he fills a need that they have on
their team and
you know from folks i've spoken to down
there they're
intrigued by the prospect of it
they believe that he does
feel a need that they have for short
area
ability to get open to be a physical
receiver to do things in the red zone
and on short yardage the patriots don't
really have anyone to do so they're
definitely interested
i just don't know if they're going to be
persuasive enough
with the quarterback situation in their
overall offense to get it done it sounds
like it's not trending that way but the
patriots definitely interested they are
interested what about the idea that
bringing in someone who
uh
from cleveland that wasn't
you know you're hearing the the the
narrative about not being a precise
route runner in a precision offense
where you need to be where you've got to
be
do your job essentially don't don't
don't ever run off of script if you
don't have to when you know when you
have a job to do and we tell you what
the script is and as long as you follow
it we we hang banners that that's not a
concern at all i just think this i mean
does he have the capacity to be precise
i'm sure he does sure not a dumb guy
i think there's a lack of respect there
probably an emboldened
guy too
by the contracts he's been given whether
it's in new york and you're playing for
ben mcadoo and you're finally saying i'm
stuck getting the ball my quarterback's
not good enough or you're in kansas city
and you're playing for kevin stefanski
who certainly has done enough to warrant
a level of respect
but you don't think you're being taken
um
you're not your role is not being taken
advantage of well enough
but i just don't think that when you
come to new england
on an eight-game audition when you have
to rehab your career you're going to
start telling the patriots how it's
going to be and what your particular
randy ratio will be i just can't imagine
as much as he acts out as immature as he
might be as divisive as he has been
that he would be dumb enough to come
into an audition period
and try and say here's the lay of the
land for obj bill
[Music]
well i'm beyond that right no i i i i
don't know how divisive he is though to
be honest with you you know what i mean
like every teammate kind of digs them
from you know uh maybe mayfield feels
differently or a couple of people in
cleveland but you know when he left the
giants
i i don't know you know what i'm saying
like i i think he would actually be an
outstanding fit for new england in a way
that i think
that bill takes
somebody else's um either problem or
supposedly declining player or
player that didn't fit in where you have
and
then they come to you
to the new england patriots and start
balling out i mean muhammad as i said
earlier uh this week that there's
there's randy moss on one end of that
scale clearly is a hall of famer and
muhammad sanu on the other end of that
scale right and
beckham would would be closer to randy
moss than than mohamed sanu in my
estimation sure would and when we talk
about this bill did give us insight a
long time ago this is a great thing
about covering the team for so long is
you get to understand
when he was
more open how his mind works he said
about guys like corey dillon right
specifically corey dylan if you look at
his resume
every problem he had was football
related now he had tough upbringing he
was a pain in the ass up in seattle and
he had all kinds of trouble as a kid
but his problems in cincinnati as a
running back were
on field
and how he was used was not off field
stuff now he certainly deviated that
from that with antonio brown his stuff
was not football related it was just
he was nuts i mean he behaved in bizarre
ways i think obj would be closer to a
guy whose issues are football related
rather than off field
so that would be to me a reason that
bill belichick would be more in the
market
for rodel beckham jr but i guess one
what we have to wonder too is what's the
upshot of the new new england patriots
2021 season do you no matter what's
going on in kansas city you know that
they're going to right the ship and be
in contention to play in if not win a
super bowl same thing with green bay
seattle
with russell wilson i would say the same
thing can change things in eight games
with new orleans it's a homecoming and
you're still playing with a hall of fame
head coach
in new england
i just don't know if the pieces are in
place because this is still rich a
rebuilding team
it's five and four
because the patriots don't bottom out
like the jaguars or the dolphins or
other teams that have to go 2 and 14 and
then rebuild
last year was their crater now they're
still rebuilding but they're playoff
contenders
tom curran here on the rich eisen show
let's get into that about what the
patriots are in 2021. i saw them and so
far a couple weeks ago with my own two
eyes and that looked like a playoff team
to me tom that was a playoff team that
was a team that went in to uh you know
cross the country all those time zones
away went into uh an opposing team's
building uh there there was seemingly
half of quincy in in the stands though
to be honest with you um you know and
surrounding areas um so
but but it still was a highly impressive
victory from the fact that um mac jones
was the guy who read the defenses and
took what was given to him and then was
able to
exploit things when he could not justin
herbert the defense that played and
balled out and turned things over just
when you needed to and then played the
game
uh smartly when the clock was winding
down by sliding to keep from going out
of bounds they were situationally more
brilliant that looked like the patriots
to me that's the not last year this year
uh
you know what is from your perspective
going on to get them to this five and
four mark and and seemingly uh back tom
the hole is greater than the sum of its
parts and they're very well coached and
they they
stayed the course defensively and
actually changed a little bit i only get
two x's and o's but they've gone away
from the man stuff and they're way more
zoned so
simpler defense generally
to run so there's fewer busts like we
saw maybe against dallas
um which cost them that game really i
mean rich you don't even have to really
squint too hard to see how this team
could be eight and one right five and
four
dallas tampa and the fumble played loss
in the opener to miami could have all
been wins again if so nuts
you know this
and candies whatever the hell it is yes
right my aunt my uncle everything else
yes um
so but i mean you look at this team
and
they're highly capable but they're never
going to blow teams out i mean they kind
of did obviously with the jets but
they're going to be very close to the
bone all year long they're going to be
close to the bone this this week with
cleveland
they have to play precisely and it's
part of the reason is they have
uncertainty in key spots and that's in
terms of protection it's at both tackle
spots where trent brown has been absent
because the injury and isaiah win is
underachieved
and it's because of a lack of
explosiveness
henry johnny smith
agawar kendrick bourne jacoby myers
they're fine as a group
but you're not walking in you the way
you would with edelman or gronkowski
and saying oh my god what are we gonna
do about this guy we better send two and
a half to him you don't have to send two
and a half to anybody on the patriots
offense and eventually that's going to
bite him and that's why bill is
essentially holding up the boombox
outside of
obj's window right now is that i think
that it is that it's got to be hey we're
just missing this
so why not roll the dice and see how far
we can get
tom curran here on the rich eisen show
the fact that they are even thinking
about let's add odell right now or they
are they're in on it i i think is just
the latest sign of how they feel like
they are in fact set at quarterback
and that that odell could be in fact uh
enticed to join belichick's organization
and team and things like that and you
know
beckham has been on record as being very
complimentary and
uh lauding belichick um because mac
jones is is
he doesn't look like a rookie man i i
didn't see that at all i saw him wait
and wait and wait for receivers to clear
against the charges he didn't panic he
threw the ball away when he should
that was not a rookie quarterback i saw
a couple weeks ago you got a good story
uh of right now of of where jones is in
his development and what the patriots
feel on that front he he has mack toad a
little bit because between last week
and this week those were his two
least impressive games really in terms
of accuracy
and i would watch that for this week
with cleveland too because the edge
rushers from carolina bothered him and
he had a fairly he was accurate but he
did not have a good second half and i
thought that
with the chargers he was
really inaccurate on some throws you're
exactly right and that's the coolest
thing about his development
is you see a player like say for
instance zack wilson throw a pick or two
early and then it's just an uh an
avalanche
with matt jones whether it's a bad
practice or a bad series in training
camp
or it's in the regular season he has a
bad series throws a pic six against the
cowboys then comes back and throws a
touchdown his resilience is ridiculous
but he has in the last two weeks
plateaued just a little bit he's playing
like closer to a rookie than than he had
been as a five-year veteran i'm not
nitpicking what your point on the
charter's game was the way he closed
that game
was
really impressive because
he didn't turn into a puddle no he fixed
it and that's what you need from a from
a young quarterback if he's going to be
shouldered with all that that that's why
to me
rich
the conversation about who the rookie
offensive rookie of the year is is kind
of a non-starter i mean it's got to be
matt jones no matter what devante smith
and jamar chase do
matt jones has
in the last calendar year
gone from alabama
gone through the draft process where he
was the fifth best quarterback and maybe
a second rounder to be
to being the fifth you know just one
take in 15th overall
unseats
cam newton the former mvp
begins the season this will start our
roles of you know
in one of the more storied places
has the team in a position to go to the
playoffs has to shoulder all that has to
be as efficient as he has been has to
succeed tom brady has to compete against
tom brady i mean
a receiver is
even an outstanding otherworldly
receiver
never going to compare to shouldering
the same load
as a good to very good quarterback and
the impact is never going to be the same
that's why to me
your offensive rookie of the year is and
should be almost always by default the
quarterback that's why i voted for
herbert over our very brilliant justin
jefferson last year who i loved
and that's why i think it should go the
same way with with jamar chase there's
naji harris too out there as well
you know
and the reason why the steelers have won
four in a row
is because he has come to the fore and
they are centering their offense around
him
and it allows ben to find the guys down
the field you know what i mean and and
roethlisberger is definitely more
upright and clean and you know so at
some point that's going to be the case
but
i had matthew judon on monday's show tom
curran and asked him about mac jones and
one of the things that i i definitely uh
followed up on when he was talking about
what what's impressive about mac jones
is it the spirit that he takes coaching
with
and i just found that interesting that a
defensive player is noticing that from
afar or he's seen it up close are they
coaching them really hard they're
getting in his ear hole and stuff like
that ridiculously hard yeah i mean they
were crushing
um carolina even though not on the
scoreboard carolina had no shot the
other day could have locked them in the
gym all day and they wouldn't have
scored a hoop
and
he had two mac jones did in the second
half he had a really sluggish drive
where he threw one
into the cheerleaders and then overthrew
one it was just sloppy looking passes
and mcdaniels just tore it to him on the
bench
and
it's just interesting because
you don't see that with a lot of rookie
quarterbacks because there's a a
mentality of cuddling bringing them
along okay he's gonna make some i mean
you get a four pick game out of zach
wilson it's like yeah we like to have a
few of those back what
just call it like you see it mm-hmm
mm-hmm that's it no i i i definitely
wanted to ask about that so a last one
for you what do you think belichick's
dialing up for this week what do you
think with baker coming in no chub
uh they just had a terrific performance
obviously against cincinnati what do you
think uh
first blush might become in cleveland's
way and what i think is one of the
marquee games of of week
i agree with you they will be playing
it'll be interesting because i don't
know if they'll go the cover two stuff
that they did
they haven't seen
um
you know the charges they they did a lot
of
you know
zone but that was a better throwing team
i don't think the chargers are that
chargers excuse me the browns are that
the browns are kind of a mirror image of
the patriots running game tight ends
pretty smart quarterback who can be
accurate
so i would say they're going to
challenge baker mayfield and see if he
can throw over the top a little bit and
they're going to when he does that rely
on your monday guest matthew judon who
is playing at
certainly a pro bowl level maybe even an
all-pro level
he's been great tom thanks for the call
appreciate it um let's let's shut down
you be well
okay that's it tom carr patriots insider
nbc sports boston everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here